the Joe Rogan experience it's
interesting that when you go to the
woods to forage for plant life it's
totally legal
yeah you could sell it yeah but if you
forage for animal life you can't do that
I think that is because of market
hunting that really decimated most of
the population of North American game
animals in the 1800's and early into the
1900s like most people associate that
with the death of the Buffalo yeah the
and it makes sense and I think I think
if there there are ways to do it where
it could be controlled I don't think I
could hunt enough meat for the for the
restaurant
but 25 seats 45 seats but you know what
do you think I do think that you know I
think it's people's right to be able to
eat well meat I think that as a human
being you have the right to try that and
if you're not a hunter if you don't know
how to go do it you have the right to
least try it and I do know in actually
Newfoundland they're allowed to serve
well game and the hunter has to go and
get a permit to sell and then he has to
bring it to a butcher that has a permit
to process it and expect it and then
that butcher can then sell to a
restaurant oh well that makes sense
yeah and it's it's controlled and like I
don't want to decimate the population I
don't want to hurt anything is that the
way to say it though Newfoundland
Newfoundland yeah I think it's call it
Newfoundland it's like a calling Chicago
Chicago
good fake Canadian I have an aunt from
there yeah I don't want market hunting
of wild game you know it's because I
love wild animals and again yeah well I
just think it's very complex that's what
I think I think just staying a lot being
a human is very complex and I think we
have very simplistic ways of looking at
it yeah I also think that it's entirely
possible that plants are communicating
with each other and they have a level of
intelligence that we don't totally
understand it's and that's supported by
data
yeah that's supported by more and more
research every day they're they're
finding out that plants have some
interconnected network of communication
with each other and that they recognize
when they're being eaten
and they changed their flavor profile to
make themselves taste terrible to
animals that are eating them there's
some communication between them and
there are some sort of a primitive
life-form that many are you are far more
complex than things that vegans won't
eat like mollusks like mollusks although
we think of them as animals they're the
simplest dumbest [ __ ] things on earth
vices did an article that questioning
whether mollusks were vegan I think for
health purposes people that are vegans
like hey man they're sustainable I mean
you can farm them you could have any
given property - I've watched something
that they were using mussels to clean up
ocean beaches filtered water and fast
and mushrooms - apparently are very
cleansing there they're trying to find
ways to use mushrooms to clean kind of
oil spills and you know yes screwed up
environmental things people should eat
mollusks they really should and they
should also eat eggs eat eggs folks just
eat them from ethical animals and I'm
just saying this just as a person who
values health yeah and a person who's I
mean I I put my body through a lot my
body has to it has to perform and it has
my whole life so I'm very very concerned
with nutrition and I'm very aware of the
impact nutrition has on physical
performance and I think eggs are
gigantic they're so goddamn good for
your health and this idea that somehow
know that you're doing something cruel
my chickens are my friends you see it
from that video that's improvement in
the pudding they're not scared of me at
all run around with they're running
around with me and I eat their eggs and
those eggs are good for you and I know
everybody can't do that but you can get
these no it's eggs and you vote with
your dollars that you're spending you
know if you go to the store and you buy
organic eggs and you buy the healthier
version yes you're paying extra buck or
two bucks or whatever it is but crack
open an egg from like the mass-produce
place and you crack open an egg from the
organic place one is like the organic
ones are like bright orange and like
super dark and even the yolk is like
really thick and then the other one it's
like pale and runny like yellow and you
you crack them and the yolks break
sometimes and they're just like it's
garbage and who knows what's in them and
what conditions those chickens are
living in a lot of times terrible
conditions I think whoever started
I mean I guess it's just economics right
and you give people the option to make
the most amount of money and not have to
account for ethics or cruelty standards
or whatever you know whatever issues
were in place that allowed factory farms
to materialize that's one of the worst
worse pieces of evidence about the
cruelty of human beings yeah it's one of
the worst it's horrific I mean and it's
it's something that I think we should
really collectively do something about
and absolutely it's one of the things
that really ramps up the the anger on
the the side of the animal rights
activist and the side of the vegans
[Applause]